allez on part à présent dans le jura à
mouchard où nous attend florence
cicolella bonjour florence vous allez
nous présenter un artisan qui rêvent de
mettre les voiles
tout en restant dans le jura bonjour à
tous à vos coeurs de l'arbois drine
entreprises ici à bouchard dans le jura
qui fabrique des objets en bois depuis
13 ans qu'est-ce que vous fabriquez
exactement cristaux points alors on
fabrique des écrans acoustiques pour des
bureaux et séparation de bureaux
fabrique des objets en bois façon et on
a aussi une gamme d'articles scolaires
que tout le monde connaît puisque c'est
oui les règles les équerres qu'on
retrouve au tableau et celle là elle a
un peu particulière que sept équerres
alors celle ci c'est une adaptation en
fait du modèle plus petit qui a été
déposée par un prof de maths
voilà qui s'appelle les caire donc c'est
une petite innovation en france et donc
on l'appelle mais on a fait le même
modèle pour le but pour le tableau pour
faire langue à l'intérieur pour vraiment
de l'intérieur qui est plus de
débordements comme ça l'angle droit est
parfait ok de l'innovation ça c'est pas
de coeur de métier aussi que fait jordan
rassure sur la machine
alors soit la machine là on est en train
de faire des pièces de tonneaux bien
particulière avec un angle bien
particulier c'est une demande en sous
traitance qu'on peut pas réaliser sur le
votre machine que celle ci bon alors
voilà votre coeur de métier et puis vous
êtes idiot je vais pas te laisser vous
portait très bien
alors vous qui aura alors la route du
rhum c'est une belle aventure en fait je
suis originaire de saint malo attendait
saint malo un bouche à malo bouchard
arrivé il ya 30 ans dans le jura pour
poursuivre mes études depuis saint malo
puisque mouchard était la seule commune
en france aux indices et dispensait des
cours d' sur l'industrie du bois vous
appeler ici je suis resté sur ma vie et
maintenant je retourne un petit peu on
va dire aux origines mais pour la bonne
cause puisque je veux montrer mon savoir
faire et faire connaître mon entreprise
au travers de plusieurs objets
personnalisés avec la licence de la
route du rhum donc on va aller voir ces
objets spécialement dédié à la route du
rhum donc là voici notre premier article
de la gamme de des objets licenciés de
la route du rhum avec des petits
porte-clés que françoise est en train de
préparer
donc ça c'est vraiment l'entrée de
garantie celle entre 8° d'entrée de
gamme à 2 euros 2 euros 50
selon lui le petit souvenir qui fait
plaisir petits goodies qui va permettre
de démarrer et qui grèvent pas le budget
alors il ya plein d'autres objets
évidemment là bas on va retrouver votre
vote collaboratrice anne le guernec
rousse un peu aux bretons c'est comme
non il me semble en fait le principe
c'est que vous avez décliné votre savoir
faire mais avec le logo route du rhum
avec la licence oui donc on est parti de
la papeterie donc les règles
après on a refait des pots à crayons et
après on a vraiment des presse-papier
support de téléphone des planches à
découper à des planches à découper pour
l'apéro évident l'association et mojito
les jeux c'est alors qu'est ce que vous
avez le droit and de l'utiliser et de
décliner parce que le logo j'imagine il
est immuable oui alors on a reçu la
charte graphique donc il y avait des
choses on n'avait pas le droit de
modifier les logos mais par contre les
éléments graphiques de la fiche ont été
repris et repenser selon le support bois
dans le plateau par exemple donc c'est
là en tant que créatrice que vous êtes
ces valeurs si oui et sur les règles
aussi décliné plusieurs modèles le le
but c'est d'avoir le plus d'objets
possibles c'est d'attirer l'oeil comment
se présente parce que vous n'avez jamais
fait ce genre de mon nom en effet le but
c'est d'être à l'équilibré à la fin de
l'opération
oui déjà c'est le minimum on va on va
maximum à quel budget pour ces petits
objets sont faits au survol un budget de
20 mille euros ce serait bien non en
termes de le l'objet le plus cher loger
plus cher par donc ça va de 2 euros 2
euros 50 jusque 30 euros oui donc on
reste quand même dans des objets
raisonnable voilà donc le but we say die
in the data leak est libre et la
finalité en fait c'est de faire
connaître mon entreprise et faire valoir
aussi notre savoir-faire pour l'objet
personnalisés puisqu'on peut imprimer
maintenant été notre technologie sur le
bois et et ce sera aussi votre rôle sur
place parce que donc là vous allez
vendre en amont mais vous serez présent
au village départ on appelle ça comme ça
dimanche de parler on sera parmi les
trois cents 300 exposants du village
votre rôle de hans à ce moment là ça
sera de tenir la boutique éphémère
pendant les 15 jours et parler de du
jura du jura notre savoir faire est ce
que vous avez déjà des touches on
commence à voir un petit peu de
retombées oui avec des boutiques de
souvenirs sur lequel on a commencé à
personnaliser des produits comme la
carte postale est aussi les pots à
crayons essentiellement sur saint malo
est là et sa région donc la côte
d'émeraude
et là vous entraîner pour les cartes
postales vous entraîner aussi d'autres
entreprises du secteur
oui je travaillais en partenariat avec
des petites entreprises du coin pour
voir le partage des savoirs et c'est
important
est-ce que les malouins connaissent un
peu le jura ont peut-être pas mouche
amérique connaissent un petit peu quand
même
surtout pour les stations de ski paul
hier l'aller reçoit c'est assez renault
mais bon pour vous c'est une aventure où
quand même fou que ça reste raisonnable
pour permettre en péril
l'entreprise s'est quand même laventure
oui d'ailleurs vous allez paulo deux pas
des skippers mais non là c'est la grande
aventure c'est la première fois donc
voilà on va essayer de limiter la casse
et puis de s'en sortir le mieux possible
et bien représentés et si vous êtes bon
pour signer dans quatre ans pourquoi on
verra on verra on n'aura pas d'élan
après après les quinze jours sur le
village est évidemment vous avez le
droit de commercialiser jusqu'à quand au
delà de la course sur un encore un an
après bon alors voilà on aura encore le
temps de voir ben voilà du made in jura
mais estampillé route du rhum
destination guadeloupe en tout cas une
belle aventure du jura à la mer merci
florence on souhaite bon vent à vos
invités pour cette belle initiative